hi i'm jenny and today i'll be talking
to you about the top security threats
apis face
as well as best practices for how to
secure your apis
let's get started
[Music]
api security is a broad field with many
vulnerabilities
threats and protection practices to take
into consideration
apis face the same threats as software
and web apps
but because they have a unique set of
vulnerabilities they also face unique
threats
we've boiled all these down to six main
security threats that you should protect
against
basic software bugs injection threats
service availability threats user
identity threats
insider threats and spam and abuse
the first api security threat is your
basic software bug
protecting against basic software bugs
is a matter of organizing regular tests
and reviews
and this is vital to your success start
by ensuring your organization has good
software engineering in place
this means using standardized coding
guidelines
and instituting code reviews ensure that
new code is tested regularly by
reproducing security issues in your own
environment
fixing them and quickly rolling them
into production
if you haven't already implement
security reviews
doing so ensures that the security
issues that one api faces will not be
repeated or resurfaced with another api
you may also consider engaging in
third-party penetration tests
in order to get a realistic picture of
how vulnerable your systems
data and apis are from an outside
perspective
apis also face injection attack threats
like sql injection
remote code execution or cross-site
scripting
injection attacks occur when malicious
code is injected into a vulnerable
software program
luckily since apis have open api
specifications
or swagger specs with well-identified
inputs and
outputs these threats are easy to
protect against using consistent input
validation
api management platforms like apogee
provide a host of policies
that allow you to easily deploy input
validation
service availability threats are also a
large concern to organizations
these attacks target apis by flooding
your network with requests
resulting in denial of service issues to
protect against these attacks
we recommend that you use the volumetric
defense tools apogee provides
such as rate limiting and quota policies
using these with other google cloud
tools like google front-end load
balancers
which are built specifically to deal
with ddos protection
is a great best practice to follow
although many people consider good
customer experience as supporting and
guiding a customer through their
purchase journey
great customer experience also means
protecting the user and their identity
at every moment in time to protect
against user identity threats
you'll want to use an api gateway that
allows you to integrate
oauth json web tokens signatures
api keys and more defense mechanisms
that validate
and ensure authentication and
authorization
with api management you don't need to
sacrifice user satisfaction for security
building and deploying a developer
portal is a great way to give your api
consumers
a self-service experience to understand
the apis you're exposing
and request the access they need plus
apogee offers api monitoring and
analytics dashboards
so that you can gain a holistic view of
the health and security of your api
programs insider threats are an
increasing
problem for enterprise security and
remind us that security breaches don't
just come from the outside in
but can also come from within with so
many
employees and contractors having access
to sensitive information
in an organization a key first step to
defend against insider threats
is to integrate your api management
system and your google cloud console
with your enterprise single sign-on
system you also want to centralize and
structure your change management
processes
so that developers have clear visibility
of any changes that are occurring to
your software infrastructure
this includes knowing who is making the
changes
what the changes are who approved them
and why the changes are being made
last but not least let's talk about spam
and abuse
a considerable amount of api traffic
comes from automated actors
that engage in credential stuffing brute
forcing and content scraping
the most important thing to remember is
that you can't secure your apis against
threats that you can't see
establish api traffic visibility through
an api management platform like
apogee where you'll be able to observe
and capitalize upon good
legitimate traffic while also being able
to identify and block against
bad actors in summary
apis face several security threats
ranging from basic software bugs
to spam and abuse api management is a
key part of your security architecture
and will help you spend less time
reacting to security issues
and more time innovating assessing
opportunities for improvement
and prioritizing security efforts based
on perceived risks
is an important part of doing business
in today's increasingly digital world
and google cloud is here to make your
security defenses
intuitive intelligent and reliable
to learn more please review the
resources below
you